i think we have someone here i think our
i think our testicular expert
is joining us
um let's see
um
howdy sir hey what's going on yeah uh
looks like you got a a red infrared
light going on there or something yeah
you know
just gotta
keep the old t-levels high you know what
i'm saying oh the t-levels it's just
that i i i'm guessing you're uh tanning
your testiculars is that what you're
there's
so do you constantly tan your testes
listen uh every waking minute of my day
is taken up by maximizing the amount of
testosterone i can put into my body okay
i am an alpha male yeah and i'm going to
make sure that i am
always an alpha male yep it's so
you look you look really alpha this
morning um with the red light shining up
on your face
it's okay you know i understand that
some betas wouldn't really get it
but uh when you're at my level of alpha
right my level of testosterone my level
of manliness
you know i what i understood about the
because i'm i'm guessing that you're
you're taking you're heeding the advice
of tucker carlson's documentary on uh
on uh sunning your ball sack is it is
that what i take is it is that the take
i'm getting here i mean you know it's
it's more or less uh
the advice that i gave him you know oh
so you so you were you were providing
the expert advice on um yes on how the
we're doing some we're doing some really
innovative revolutionary things that are
happening on uh
on red light
oh okay i see so tell me about tell me
about um
red lighting your gonads how this makes
you more of a man i'm not sure how this
works well you know i see a lot of betas
uh you know up late
gaming away
you know point dexter is really a
staying up late using that blue light
and what does the blue light do the blue
light really brings down your
testosterone levels okay really you know
the b in blue really stands for beta
okay oh i see it's gonna be democrat so
the blue light the blue light is like
it's like a democrat thing the red light
is like a red pill uh right wing type
thing i'm not saying that you get woke
from using red light but you get pretty
woke
i mean you wake up to the reality that's
around you all right what what is the
reality about your gonads that you have
to red light them
i mean uh it's really just waking up to
the god-given greek roman
just muscular man that we were meant to
be okay you know just wrestling
skin-to-skin man to man
bro
to bro you know okay so so what you're
saying is is that that you get naked and
you tan your sack and then you wrestle
each other once your sacks are tan
i mean
essentially yeah oh okay that sounds uh
very
manly
it is right have you ever wrestled with
a man
um
not not not after i've stand my sack no
i am you know now i have a really beta
well that could be so let me ask you let
me ask you alpha cuck uh dr alpha cuck
here let me ask you if
if you tan your sack because i'm really
confused by this
because
um
if if your goal is to be more manly
right to uh i don't know spread your
seed throughout the earth
wouldn't it
very
well wouldn't microwaving your your your
gonads reduce your sperm count or how
does this work
look i don't expect a non-uh medical
professional to understand the sciences
behind this technology because it's
pretty advanced i'm sure it is i'm sure
it is but look look look look what i
will say is
using
red light therapy
has
an immense amount of benefits to it okay
you know you're treating any skin
conditions any rashes you may have you
know don't want to get a shot of some
sort it's natural immunity that goes
into your body straight to the
mitochondria straight into the cell now
when it comes to your privates you know
as you put it your your gonads yeah
that's a direct shot of testosterone
it's like if you put
17
shots of testosterone like you went you
went in and you wanted to get you know
added testosterone because you were you
were low in levels this is all natural
no jab
straight to the balls yeah it's it's
really not surprising that um anti-jab
uh anti-master types like you
are microwaving their their nut sex it's
not really surprising that they're
french frying their balls um so so let's
let's talk about the uh the the other
the kind of this the sausage in the room
because
to me when you're um
tanning your your sack as it were
yeah
well it's not tanning it's
therapizing okay what is it what are you
doing
therapizing your testicles is yes
it's
so it's like a testy
testicular therapy so it's almost like a
test drive a testy festive for yeah is
that it attached again
it's clear that a beta like yourself
wouldn't really understand the nuances
of uh testicular tanning i'm just i'm
just trying to make sure it's hip you
know maybe you should get like a strobe
light that kind of you know strobes as
opposed to just one red light that seems
to be pretty unsafe for people who have
uh yeah any sort of uh light sensitivity
you know oh okay okay so you're sensing
the doctor here and i'm telling you
right now that people do have
light
uh sensitivities and i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna put their their health at risk
by putting flashing lights this isn't
some sort of techno dance club where you
just drop acid and just
blow whistles and
swing around uh glow sticks
this is not a joke you think do you
think this is a joke uh yeah i'm saving
livestream i'm saving i am saving lives
so so do you ever naturally tan your
sack like i don't know you layouting
these are very dangerous okay okay that
so so why does uva uvb you know you just
gotta go straight to the red light oh
okay so you gotta you can't blue light
it you can't sunlight no no it's like
the song turn on the red light
you know that song no i don't know that
song can you uh give us a uh um
that's all that i remember from the song
okay here it goes turn on the red light
is that why you wear those glasses every
day is that where you wear those glasses
to protect your eyes because obviously
you know you you can't protect your nuts
you got to make sure your nuts have
enough testosterone well see i've got to
protect your eyes right the eye
protector the red light is direct you
know for me it's not so much for the red
light on my yellow sunglasses the yellow
sunglasses are an anti-blue light an
anti-beta light oh okay so they blocked
they blocked the libtard um
testosterone levels that make you drop
it's like uh it's like in that movie
uh they live he puts on the sunglasses
and realizes oh the reality that's
beyond you know and with these
sunglasses right here it helps wake me
up to the reality that's around you know
so livestream media in other places you
know you got these quack doctors saying
you should get a covered shot right
these so where did you get your degree
from doc what what what what um what
level of expertise do you hold
uh i got it from herverd university
her what was that
herbert university herverd what what is
hervard it's like a
look how do you how do you how do you
spell herbert i i can't how do you spell
it it sounds like you're just trying to
say harvard but you're saying herbert
it's herbert it's a cousin school of
harvard it's a cousin huh yeah it's like
twice removed but it's a cousin school
like this is like cousin school down in
arkansas or something or am i in alabama
oh okay alabama well yeah they got a
great great great great great program
over there uh at her
herbert herbert pervert herbert
university so you know not a lot of
doctorate or but uh we're doing some
very
very
innovative uh things down there you know
i was very i was there down there down
down there yes indeed down there and i
was uh very um
privileged and grateful to be a part of
the program you know i actually
graduated uh
top of my class oh okay what do they
call that down there at uh herbert when
you graduate to the top of your class
is that
well they they said it was summer come
loud
summer come loud oh okay well that's you
know that's what they wrote down on my
uh my uh diploma
zuma zuma come loud okay well you know
that
i guess i i guess that could happen down
there pervert in alabama
so when are you going to make a joke
it's a real pleasure i know i i'm i'm
sure i'm i'm trying not to i came on the
show to talk about red light therapy
right you know i figured i would give
you uh i'm literally giving you a
hands-on demonstration right now a
rather hands-off demonstration okay yeah
so have you washed your hands this
morning do you the red light
actually the red light uh works as a
sanitization
uh tool yeah so basically with the red
light you don't have to take showers so
so let me ask you let me ask you because
you know as a guy who does not red light
his balls i don't tan my balls i don't
know that's unfortunate that sounds
pretty unfortunate for you yeah it's
certainly it certainly is a problem that
i don't have um i'm just thinking though
as i think about the logistics of
tanning you know a guy's sack
um that you know you would have to do
something you know to loop up the the
old uh sausage because there's you know
you got um you got a few things going on
down there not just right i'm trying to
figure that out i will say you know of
all the things you've asked so far
that's actually the best uh actual like
question you've had okay so could you
elaborate what um
what what a guy would do if he was gonna
tan right as well i mean here look
let's think of it like this you know if
you if you were to go out
into the sun you know you put sunscreen
or suntan lotion you're not just going
to go straight skinned to the grill you
know you're not going to just heat it up
and burn yourself because that would
just be idiotic and not safe now what
you got to do
is it's a combination between coconut
oil okay coconut oil
avocado oil these are two oils that have
high
burning uh temperature rates you know so
you can put them in a high high degree
on the pan if you want to cook something
up they are uh they you know they're
better than grape seed oil they're
better than sunflower seed oil they're
better than olive oil okay you want to
use a combination of that plus a little
bit of a generic walgreens lubriderm
it's not aluminum you don't have to go
store you have to go name brand you just
have to get a generic walgreens brand i
find that that has the best uh lotion to
water viscosity uh ratio there now if
you were to put all three of those
together it's a it's a quick one one one
ratio okay one to one to one very simple
for your viewers out there who want to
listen just understand it's very simple
you can get it yourself from you know
you probably buy all three from a
walgreens honestly
but what you want to do is you want to
mix those together you want to put it
into the freezer
okay and you want to keep that for about
30 minutes
now and now you just got to watch it
because there's going to be a there's
going to be a top layer that is on the
uh
on the top of what you've done okay you
want to scrape that off and that is what
you want to use
mmm so so you want a little bit it's
only a little bit but remember it's a
combination of of avocado oil
coconut oil and a store brand lotion uh
very similar to
uh lubriderm but not name brand
lubriderm okay so when you're so when
you're when you're toasting your
avocados
um
um do you dip them in the fryer or i'm
not real sure i you know it looks like
it looks like what you have on your
balls is a is a space heater not really
a infrared it does provide heat it does
keep you warm in cold conditions you
know you know the balls are
one of the areas that actually is very
sensitive to temperature and it can
actually regulate your whole body yeah
right
i understand most
most that's why if you saw this
documentary they were they were
completely naked
with only that and that shows you how
powerful the human body is you know if
you're straight pushing testosterone
into the body okay the whole especially
through through the
through your mid-range
uh
you're able to warm up the whole body
it's actually pretty amazing what the
body can do from a from a medical
standpoint you know scientifically
speaking so let me ask you dr nutsack
let me ask you
um
if this truly is a problem this low t
thing because to be honest with you the
tucker carlson documentary really seems
like uh just an avenue to make sure that
the american people know that hey
uh non-experts you should look at them
as experts kind of like you who get your
your your cracker jack degree from
herbert um
red lighting degree um it seems like the
documentary with tucker carlson really
is just a ruse to uh not only to you
know spew out anti-gay hate uh tropes
and hate um but to also make it to where
people like you seem to be experts but
don't know a [ __ ] thing is it is that
am i right in that alley am i am i
probably are you claiming that this is
all just a
rouge uh
well i mean i don't know are you are you
saying that my medical degree from
herverd university and all the all of
the testing and and studies that i've
done and actually sat over on my own
board you're saying that this is all
just made up you're saying that i'm just
in it for the grift and that's what
tucker carlson is doing yeah that's
that's exactly what i'm saying uh and i
guess my next question would be is when
are you booked to go on the joe rogan
podcast because i figure that's probably
your next step is to go on joe rogan you
know
to answer your first question um
i don't want to speak for tucker uh it
seems pretty genuine you know we do i
wouldn't want to speak for tucker or two
tucker either but yeah go ahead you know
i we didn't um what i will say this is
uh we did a a treatment therapy together
okay
uh you know together yeah we embraced it
was great it was wonderful you know we
had uh see
see you tan your balls together is that
how you do it i don't know well you're
uh what do you think we're savages we're
using two different uh
lights that are reflecting the opposite
way
so you stand face to face we're never
touching really and you know we're not
touching in that way i mean get your
mind out of the gutter we are embracing
trying to figure it out wholeheartedly
with our arms and our chest oh okay so
you are you are uh touching in in that
sense
oh okay okay so what about my second
question all right are you going to
experiment with joe rogan
what i will say is uh
on that circuit there's a lot of people
that i'm actually uh in communication
with right now joe rogan is one of the
people that i am planning a session to
go on his show
the other
is i'm actually talking to a few other
people uh elon musk we're talking about
adapting a uh
a
testicle tanning feature in the new
tesla model so wait wait wait it's going
to be a tesla
testicle tanning feature is it what
you're saying that's right
it's a tesla testicle tanning trademark
pending uh we're working together on
that well um so basically while you're
driving you can be treating
uh yourself for low t levels you know
we're putting the the t in tesla and now
is testosterone
so so really
since you're getting so um intuitive
with the uh
tesla testicle tanner um how much of a
problem is this really and really is it
only affecting um republican men because
it seems like only conservative
republican men are really concerned
about finding new ways to uh tan their
balls so they have
a higher testosterone level when they
could do i don't know they could take
things like testosterone it really seems
kind of like we've established from the
pandemic uh
no jab for me okay right no jab
just just avoid it just so you want to
get away from so even if you knew that
it was testosterone in the in you would
not take the testosterone you know
because here's the thing it's like uh
there are rumors many people are saying
i don't want to say it's me or but i
will say this that uh
there are these
you know they they talked about with the
vaccines but there are these micro chips
these little nano bites that are in
there you know and they and they
basically put themselves in the
testosterone now if you were to then go
to the doctor and say hey listen i have
low t levels i want to get treated for
testosterone they say great let me break
you with the jab now here's the thing
that people don't realize once they jab
you
those little little nano bites those
little little little microchips that are
in there
they're going to turn from testosterone
to estrogen and why would they
why would they do that
because it's all it's all uh it's it's
all a plan from the from the democrats
the deep state they're they're they're
coming after people you know
they're trying to make you submissive
and as an alpha male you have to stand
up you have to tell people who you are
and what you stand for and you say i
stand for testosterone i don't stand for
that
so let me
so if you stand for testosterone because
it sounds like you're really uh
referring to a medical problem which uh
some men some men actually uh
have a lower testosterone level as
others and right red light is the cure
remember well turn on the red light yeah
i know that i know you know the one
we're
lying to that song that's all that
matters here's the thing is women you
know that women have testosterone too
right
you know that that's a thing
um
you know that they yeah women women
actually have a level of testosterone
did you know that
that that that testosterone is just a
hormone you know that right
no that's that testosterone high higher
low levels of testosterone don't keep
you um i don't know being like a
responsible person or a good father or a
good partner or or even someone who
would love someone no no no that's not
true that's not true women don't have
testosterone that's not true that is not
true i
am
yeah see see that's the thing is i i
understand that that's not what we
learned at harvard university well i
understand that your degree at herbert
did not provide you i don't know like um
facts but the fact is is that men have
estrogen and women have testosterone no
we don't yeah only the betas have
estrogen real men have 100
testosterone and this red light actually
pushes the bounds of what's humanly
known for mankind and what is possible
with testosterone so what would happen
what would happen what do you surmise
would happen if a woman used this red
light on her
i don't know used it on her lady parts
what do you think would happen do you
think do you think something magical
would happen and she her testosterone
levels would increase the testosterone
levels that she has do you think by
tanning her genitals that would happen
because a lot of women believe it or not
i don't know if you know this
a lot of women actually tan
in a tanning bed which is not so similar
but kind of similar to you tanning your
balls with a red light you understand
that because women do that they don't
get quote unquote
manlier you know that right well because
they're not using red lights silly
they're using yellow lights
oh oh so or sometimes they use just uh
blue light that's straight from a
fluorescent tube so that's what makes
you know
pushing the estrogen and the beta level
man
that people are trying to be you know i
know
go ahead go ahead no i'm just saying red
light is the best you know i'm not
saying that red lights matter but they
matter oh so red lights red lights
matter they may matter
oh jesus so so did i surprise you to the
fact that women actually have a level of
testosterone i'm gonna dispute that fact
i need to see uh what your research
is i'm gonna i'm gonna i can prove you
wrong i can go i'm gonna i'm gonna go
right to back to herbert university i'm
gonna speak with my actual professors
and who is your professor who was your
professor down there at herverd
university
what are you trying to dox them now oh
no i'm just i'm just saying you know
there's an incredible
game i'm not going to play into this
game it sounds like you're trying to get
personal information private information
about my professors and then try to use
that in some
democratic liberal
manipulative way
if if it is really a university then
they would probably list on their
website um
who their professors are so i mean you
know you just use the process of you
know elimination and you would figure
out who the red light testicle taken
well you know what if people if people
you know didn't trust me then you know
again why am i in communication with
people like joe rogan yeah
elon musk
uh uh alex jones is another one does
alex jones tan his nut sack he's an
investor in my company oh okay so is
that why he's filing bankruptcy because
he kind of it kind of went south with
the red nutting thing the red light nut
sack thing
i mean i've received
plenty of money from him i don't see any
financial issues that i know of i'm not
too privy on the whole bankruptcy
situation right but i can tell you from
my own personal experience alex jones is
a great advocate you know he's actually
a pretty good affiliate in terms of
getting people to sign up
to to tan their nut sex
so um you know some other names that
come to mind that people like alex jones
and they're kind of in the same uh
red light district as you would put it
um
you know what that's actually not a bad
uh label you know maybe i should maybe i
should make a an area where where you
come you come and you get treated in the
red light district huh
yeah i think that would i i think that
could be sure you know what i'm going to
use that i'm not going to pay you for
the idea i'm not going to use that you
can have the idea come to the red light
district to the red light to get your
treatment you know
well
so there are a couple other uh [ __ ]
that are that remind me of this red
light district there's a guy named roger
stone he's real good friends with
roger yeah roger's a good guy yeah he's
a customer is he also an investor he's
just a customer no no he's uh not not an
investor but he's you know if i had to
put out there a number one customer
roger stone is a is a great guy you know
the t levels on that man are off the
chart honestly like
we you know i we just did a we just did
a six month uh kind of test to see where
he was you know a test for the test
and i got to tell you right now that boy
uh
he was greater than 100 didn't think it
was possible but i'm going to be using
him for a new case study and i'm going
to submit for the uh approval from
herverd university so so what you're
saying is roger roger fries his stones
is that what you're saying
is roger fry's his stones with avocado i
wouldn't say he fries them but again you
know i honestly tony i should be hiring
you for my marketing i mean you've got
red light district we've got uh rogers
stone stones you know i'm not going to
say it's completely accurate but i see
where you're going with it okay well you
know i wasn't here i wasn't really
bought into you when i first arrived you
know you seemed very much like a skeptic
however i see i feel like i'm turning
you around you know i'm going to
absolutely red well you didn't give me
the red pill you showed me the red light
so one last person that i'd like to ask
about if they're a customer not because
i'm not sure that they're into the red
light thing and tan and their balls uh
it's a guy who likes spray tan a lot it
really seems like rub on spray tan i'm
wondering if um if if there's a if
artificial tanning your balls if that
has the same effect as the red light
which is no effect probably
um on your testosterone levels so can
you spray tan your balls like the cheeto
dust monster donald trump which spray
tan is faced is there is there a theory
that you have where if you uh have an
artificial tanner on your nut sac if
that would uh right that'll cause cancer
what would cause cancer uh
listen there's only one way to properly
treat testosterone okay it is the right
only one so there's only one way it's
the red light now if you're spray
tanning here's the thing what i will say
is uh donald trump for
you know all of the craziness there
donald trump's actually a true beta okay
i'll i'll tell you that right now he's
not actually now you're really putting
yourself out there i am but you know
what i mean for the amount of money i've
made off this little red light here on
people's balls uh helping them with
their testosterone
i've got a whole
whole war chest but i can tell you this
much that man donald
trump he's a true beta
and uh yes i know there have been rumors
of him uh artificially you know
treating
his balls with uh with spray tan yeah
and what i can tell you is
spraying
you know red spray paint on your
genitals is not the same thing okay
okay
that's that is what i've heard um you
know i i heard uh that's what he did and
people uh you know were asking inquiring
me for my medical advice my professional
medical advice you know coming to me and
saying you know as the student of
herverd university you know summa come
loud they want to know
um
how do you know is this the same thing
and i know no only an idiot would spray
tan uh spray tan as balls with uh
with with red
uh acrylic spray paint right um
so your balls turn red when you red
light them because i i figured it'd just
tan no no they don't they don't turn red
that's the thing you know i i i don't
know where uh donald trump got that idea
that spray painting was the same effect
as this this tan
uh this treatment of testosterone but i
can tell you for a fact you know i've
seen some photos um for you know people
who shall remain unnamed uh in terms of
inquiring about how to deal with this
and i can tell you right now
that uh
he's you know he's trying to fake it you
know he's uh the estrogen levels the
beta levels on that man are incredibly
high and uh i'm sorry to say but he's
not a true alpha and well definitely not
uh
i'm not doing what he should be doing i
don't doubt that he's not he's not an
alvid i don't doubt that he's not a beta
and i think it has nothing to do with
what he's spraying on his balls or doing
with his balls i mean i would say that
he's going to get cancer from spraying
his balls with red spray paint but
that's
that's just my medical opinion and my
blacksmith i'm sure
yeah i'm sure your your medical opinion
is worth uh a lot
uh coming from uh suda come loud is that
what you said sue to come along from
herbert university down there
from herbert university top of my class
alabama well thank you dr nutsac we
appreciate you joining us today is it dr
nutsack is that is that what you go by
red or what's the dr newt sock
oh dr nuked suck okay
it's uh it's european okay i got you so
the european uh fake doctor that got his
degree from herbert university down in
alabama real doctor wheels
um whose best customers is alex jones uh
and roger stone and elon musk thank you
doctor for joining us and anytime giving
us that riveting information on red
lighting your balls um i i wish the best
of frying to you sir and you have a good
day and let me know if you're uh if your
audience wants a discount just i'd be
afraid of people you know no we don't we
don't need a promo code we don't need a
promo code for you but i'll make a new
one right now it'll call be red light
district if you want to call if you want
to go to dr newt
sock.com slash
red dash light
go to that website and enter the
discount code i'll make it right now
after i get out this interview um
uh red light district you know and if
anything uh uh r
l
d okay
i'll do a shorter one for you rld got it
got it thanks doc we appreciate you
stopping by we will not have you back
thank you very much everyone stick
around right after this break